there's like seven different ways I've
seen people talk about their net worth
most of them false one of the things
that I have feel like I've learned is
the wealthier you become the more
amorphous what net worth even means is
when you're poor you know exactly what
you have because you don't have much and
you can count it on your fingers right
when you have a lot then it's like well
what's the value of the 28 stake I have
in this business that we're not planning
on selling and we're reinvesting profits
that do so when people are like this
guy's worth a billion dollars it's not
like he has a billion dollars in his
bank account he just owns something that
is worth a billion dollars which is very
different